We never thought this day would actually
come, but Lucifer, a fan-favorite series
that had escaped certain death twice, has signed
off for good with Season 6. The creative dramedy
about Lucifer Morningstar abandoning hell for
Los Angeles premiered in 2016 on Fox. It ran
for three seasons before it was canceled.
Netflix quickly stepped in to save the show
for Season 4. Although the super-sized fifth
season was supposed to be the show's swan song,
the streamer surprised everyone by renewing
Lucifer for a sixth season, which debuted in
September with 10 episodes. Among its highlights,
the final season explores Lucifer's life as a
parent and brings back some familiar faces,
like Officer Diggs from the series' pilot.
But there was one important character who didn't
get as much screen time as they had in previous
seasons: Chloe's daughter, Trixie.
"My name's Beatrice, but everybody calls me Trixie."
"That's a hooker's name."
"What's a hooker?"
"Ask your mother."
While Trixie was never a major player on Lucifer,
she was central to both Chloe and Lucifer's lives.
Trixie enjoyed a close relationship with Lucifer
over the years. But, in Season 6, she was
relegated to attending science camp. The series
instead focused on the arrival of Lucifer and
Chloe's daughter, Rory. Rory traveled back in time
from the future to meet the father she never knew.
As such, Trixie appeared sporadically,
and her time on screen mostly focused on
mourning the death of her father. So, where
was Trixie for the majority of the season?
When Netflix renewed Lucifer for what was
believed, at the time, to be its last season,
Scarlett Estevez began booking new roles and
ostensibly planning for life after the show.
Estevez joined the fourth season of the Disney
Channel series Bunk'd in 2019, which may have
been a cause for concern amongst the fans
looking forward to the character's return.
"I'm Parker, I've heard so much about you, andquite
frankly I'm a little frightened.”
“Aw, thank you."
In February 2021, co-showrunners
Joe Henderson and Ildy Modrovich assured fans
that they would still see Trixie in the second
half of Season 5 and Season 6. They explained:
"[In] both Season 5B and Season 6, fans will still
definitely get their Trixie fix. We adore
Scarlett and shuffled things around a bit
to make sure we could keep the tale of
the future President of Mars going!"
The shuffling occurred because Estevez had
also booked a Christmas movie for Disney
titled Christmas Again. Filming occurred at the
end of 2020, which overlapped with production
on Season 6 of Lucifer. But that wasn't the
13-year-old actress' only other work commitment.
She had also landed a lead role in an
upcoming Disney Channel original series.
It seems that Estevez's smaller presence
in the final season was the unfortunate
result of scheduling conflicts. That's a shame
considering how much fun it sounds like Estevez
had on the set of Lucifer. Scarlett Estevez
is still a young talent, but she is already
a pro at doing interviews. In the past, she has
spoken about her experiences filming "Lucifer"
and based on what she's had to say, it sounds
like she had a blast working with her co-stars.
While speaking with Daily Dead,
Estevez was asked about Tom Ellis
and Lesley-Ann Brandt. Her response was glowing:
"Tom is awesome! He has daughters, so he is really
good with kids. Lucifer doesn't really enjoy being
around Trixie, but I would say in real life he's
happy when I'm around. [And] Lesley-Ann is the
best. We have a really great relationship offset.
We've gotten together on days we aren't filming a
couple times, and I really love being around her."
And it's not just her fellow cast members
who Estevez loved working with. On Twitter,
the series' showrunner Ildy Modrovich posted
a behind-the-scenes pic of herself and Estevez
with the caption:
"[Scarlett Estevez]
is truly an angel in this earth."
Estevez responded with her own tweet, writing,
quote, "Love this!! Sending you a big hug."
It looks like even though her screen time
in the final season ended up being limited,
Estevez enjoyed her stint on the show. Luckily,
fans looking to revisit the character on Lucifer
can now stream all six seasons on Netflix.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.